les employés de cette ferme dans la
région de ni pro petrovsk sont encore
sous le choc le niveau de l'eau est
descendu de plus de 8 mètres nous n'en
avons plus assez les vergers vont mourir
nous n'avons plus de système
d'irrigation la flore et la faune sont
déjà mortes
mais elle ne parvient pas à ramper
jusqu'à l'eau alors elle va mourir aussi
et ça va puer
et les gens nous sommes 8 dans ma
famille mon beau-fils est rentré blessé
par balle du front comment nettoyer ses
blessures nous n'avons plus d'eau
comment survivre en tant qu'humain
[Applaudissements]
Mireille
les pompes qui prenaient l'eau de cette
partie du réservoir de kakovka pour
irriguer les cultures aujourd'hui les
pompes sont à l'arrêt quand le barrage a
sauté la pression de l'eau a détruit le
canal
pour tenter de sauver ses cultures
Mireille l'eau et ses collègues prennent
de l'eau dans cet étang mais cela ne
suffira pas
de la baisse il ne nous en reste plus
que pour une semaine
cette ferme est gigantesque presque 4000
hectares et un gros employeurs nous
avions de grands projets nous étions en
train de travailler de nous développer
de booster l'économie et de fournir des
emplois et regardez tout ce dur labeur
pour rien
[Applaudissements]
les fermiers ne se laissent pas abattre
les travaux pour réparer le système de
pompage ont déjà démarré mais l'eau
continue de s'écouler du réservoir et
personne n'a de solution pour l'arrêter